Harry on va nous on va on va s'affronter
dans un nouveau jeu c'est la guerre d'd
d'accord la guerre d'd vous allez venir
avec moi au centre de la scène c'est
très simple il y aura des défis des
défis à réaliser les gages dans l'ordre
ils sont très simples il y a avalé une
grosse cuillère d'arissa oh non oh non
mettre un bas sur la tête et chanter
quoi ma gueule pendant que l'autre tire
en arrière sur le bas il y a une
perruque faite avec de la mousse à rasé
il y a une poup fiction puisil y a un
poupe qui est là il y a mettre une rose
dans sa bouche comme dans votre
spectacle venez Harry et don et a donné
à Moctar qui la récupère dans sa bouche
on était bien il y a le ballon de farine
a éclaté au-dessus de la tête de mais
pourquoi on était bien on était en train
de rigoler on était bien on était une
ambiance bon enfant pourquoi tu veux
absolument écoute finissons
[Applaudissements]
alorsce que alors har moi moi je ferai
tous les gages si je perd c'est très
simple on va lancer le D celui qui fait
le plus gagne bien sûr et l'autre fait
le gage alors c'est très simple vous
vous avez le droit à un joker à un
moment si vous avez vraiment quelque
chose de trop chaud vous pouvez demander
à un des manre arbitraire comme ça non
c'est vous qui décidez non non non non
c'est vous qui décidez c'est celui que
vous aimez le moins voilà
celui alors attention Harry on va jouer
pour le moment c'est simple c'est la
perruque m'en fous c'est moi qui
commence la perruque de mousse à
[Applaudissements]
rasé je vais vous dire
c'est la
per priori la mousse
r d pas c'est plutô sympa comme
voilà
ser attention perruque de B
j'adore laiss pas la faire moi oui quand
même attends en fait c'est comme les
chouchous si vous voulez je vous mets un
petit peu comme ça voilà merci voilà
attendecusez-moi voilà et bien devant
bien devant bien devant dégage bien
devant oui bien devant bien devant bien
dégagé jeis
la alors attention récupérez votre d har
récupérez votre d non mais c'est merci
il est propre il reste propre bien
entendu il reste propre atttion on joue
maintenant attendss comme ça c'est
important quand même pour tu pu bien
fairemion ça va on joue maintenant pour
la cuillère d'arissa oh la vache je
m'enou c'est Mo qui commence non alors
éliminé puisque vous êtes sorti
du mais ça ne compte pas je suis désolé
Harry Harry il faut le lancer ici
attendez pourquoi vousz pourquoi parce
que j'ai raison mais non mais non il
faut le lancer ici Harry allez-y
lancez-le doucement et la musique est
géniale la musique pour illustrer la r
mais c'est c'est magnifique allez-y
c'est parti vous voulez démarrer oui
allez-y c'est vachement bien 4 c'est
fort c'est pas évident non c'estyil s'il
te plaît ah tu es éliminé toi aussi oh
éliminé C non
non jamais de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vie alors je vous on me dit on me dit
qu'on ne peut pas non mais on peut pas
c'est gagn non moi
je on peut pas merci voilà merci
voilà
[Applaudissements]
ça va ê Tom elle est très fort non c'est
rien alors comme vous êtes l'invité
demi- cuuillère voilà demi-
cuuillère tu un petit peu non pas
beaucoup non pas B cou hein pas B cou
c'est bon alors ça va c'est mignon c'est
sympa c'est sympa to ça va ça va alors
voilà allez Harry Harry maintenant on
joue on joue je vous le dis on joue pour
le
P on joue maintenant Harry pour le pool
fiction pool fiction attention il va pas
bien du
[Musique]
tout allez ça va oh c'est pas la petite
bête qui va manger la grosse
voilàien bah
voilà bah ça va ok vas-y il ple me je te
dire quelque chose sans rigoler har je
te jure que c'est vrai il y a quelqu'un
qui voulait
absolument je savais je savais je le
sentais alors
[Applaudissements]
on joue pour le poupe le poupe qui est
là et il faudra rouler une pelle au
poup j'ai fait
pire attention c'est parti cro c'est le
P
vaberasy
commenceainant c'est c'est la moyenne
oh alors on refait attention vite vite
vite vite c'est pour le pou attention
attendez jamais le pou ici non
non vas-y allez-y har vous démarrez ou
je démarre allez-y je démarre allez-y
non pardon tu démarre
vas-y non non c'est C c'est cassé à vous
à
vous oh là là ça sent pas bon
ça sent le pou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pap
[Applaudissements]
P merci
har oh là là oh là
[Musique]
là